hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are returning to the
capablanca saga as we already mentioned
we've shown one game from this
tournament already it's the rice
tournament of 1916 in New York our
Capablanca defeated in round one mr. Roy
Turnbull black and thank all of you for
sending me that photo as I couldn't find
a photo so I had to use the hoodie guy
but in this game kappa blanka faces mr.
Neville Williams banks and he is he was
considered one of the few people that
have mastered both checkers and chess in
his entire life he played over over 1300
blindfold checkers games and he played
his first blindfold checkers game at the
age of 6 and he was a very strong player
as you will see in this game throughout
his career well one of the strongest
players he defeated were a friend James
Marshall and he also defeated Isaac our
son if you don't if you haven't heard of
him means you are a new subscriber to
this channel but I will put a link in
the description below the first thing
you will see is a link to Isaac our
dance immortal game I warmly recommend
it to everyone it is just a beautiful
masterpiece so if you have the time to
check that out as well but getting back
to this game this is around two of the
rice tournament and mr. Neville Williams
Bank has the white pieces he opens the
game with efore and it's I really
enjoyed this game and you will see why
we have e 5 by Capablanca Knight to f3
Knight to c6 and of course the real
Lopez Bishop to b5 kappa blanka goes for
more fees defense we have a 6 and we
have d exchange variation Bishop
captures D captures and now d4 if there
are some newer well if you just started
learning about chess maybe you're
thinking about why not capture the 5
points well it's just that after black
goes Queen d4 actually attacks both your
knight and your efore point you have to
go back with the knight and then black
will just recapture the pawn with check
you will have to block and then black
and either capture or develop the bishop
but either way black at least equalizes
but even retains a better position so
after D captures on c6 exchanging Bishop
for a night with d4 so d 4e captures
with Queen captures Queen captures
Knight captures and Bishop to d6 by
Capablanca so here mr. Neville Williams
banks decided to give up the disrepair
early he went for the exchange variation
and now as you'll see he's a very strong
player
we have castles by white and not Knight
to e7 already you might think but why
not nice to f6 well this would be a
tactical error even though it seems like
you're developing the piece while
attacking a pawn where I can just push a
5 here and and now you can well you can
go Bishop c5 and then it's a it's
playable but you cannot capture the pawn
that's the problem because rook e1 just
wins the piece so after castles with 97
by Capablanca Knight the d2 a very
excellent idea there because after
capablanca developed the Knights to e7
the bishop no longer has this
opportunity of returning to e7 and here
mr. banks wants to go Bishop to c4 and
Reed capablanca of his very strong
bishop pair here kappa blanka castles
and we have nice to see for Capablanca
goes Knight to g6 and now Knight
captures a bishop on e6 and while you do
read a couple on coffees bishop pair you
also fix his pawn structure so C
captures on d6
we have Bishop to e3 and now this is a
well here a couple Blanca decides he
will give up the light square bishop for
tonight but that he also wants to open
up a DF file because after after this
happens couple Monaco pushes f5 with he
captures and now Bishop captures Knight
captures and rook captures and here
kappa blanka decided to go willingly
into this in game he does have a knight
against the bishop the material and the
board is equal but there is a one thing
you have to see that the black will have
a very nice game because well all of his
pawns on the Queen side are on light
squares he will put d5 at some point and
then all of the points will be on light
squares the darks for Bishop even though
he can attack both sides of the board he
can't really do anything to threaten the
pawns on light squares on the Queen side
and due to the white pawns being on a B
and C file the rooks will have a hard
time targeting the pawn so it will be it
will be easier for for Kappa Blancas
night to find targets than for mr. banks
bishops bishop
so rook a to d1 going after the d6 pawn
and now
d 5 and now f 4 you might think when at
sea for let's say pawn captures and then
play for some activity we drove to d7 it
doesn't really work
black will keep it the extra pawn just
go rook f7 and even with rook F to d1
just rookie 8 and there is no way of
winning back the pawn it's just a pawn
up for black you can capture and after
captures rook c7 check you can just
block rock e7 so white it doesn't really
gain anything so even though you can try
to play actively you will not gain
anything by it
so f4 here banks wants to limit the
movement of Kappa Blancas Knight taking
away the e5 square from him and also g3
is coming so the h4 Square will not be
available for couple on cuz night either
capablanca goes rook to e8 attacking the
bishop and here is the first moment
where it really shows that mr. banks
isn't really uncouple Blancas level here
you have to play Bishop to b2 but it's
not at all clear right away here rook to
f3 was played just defending the bishop
capablanca went rook to e4 with a triple
attack against the f4 pawn trying to
bait out g3 and here g3 was indeed
played here we have G 3 by mr. banks and
now feel free to pause the video and try
to find what was Kappa Blancas idea in
this position I'll give you a couple of
seconds as it is a very nice idea for
those of you who are able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
maneuver of knights and for those of you
who just wanna enjoy the show Knight to
e5 that's the point when you play the g3
the rook on f3 is is no longer guarded
so pawn captures results in rook
captures rook and you know you're just
on the exchange at least so here you
have to move the rook and if you move
the rook well you will lose the bishop
but it's not a problem as the knight is
also under attack
but here capablanca just wins a pawn and
he enters a favorable endgame for him so
we have look F 2 F 1 and tau comes rook
captures on e3 pawn captures night and
now Capablanca decides it's better to
play this position with only a pair of
rooks on the board and with two pairs of
rooks we have rook captures King
actress and now Luke captures on e5 here
kappa blanka wins a pawn and now it's a
it's a rockin game with with kappa
blanka being a pawn up that's just a
nightmare to play against but mr. banks
will of course try we have looked to be
three just gaining some activity for the
rook a nice roof lifts you will be able
to control both maybe maybe black king
and maybe also try to attack couple
Blancas queen sized pawns king to f7 not
allowing the white rook to the cutoff
the Capablanca skink we have rook to b3
attacking the pawn and now just rook to
e7
now capablanca wants to get over to the
well not there but over to the Queen
side with the King will help out with
the defense of the points and then kappa
blanka can activate his rook and start
pushing his extra pawn rook to f3 check
with King to e8 and now the rook just
returns doesn't allow kappa blanka
struck to activate King to d8 and not
look back to f3 we have King to c7 and
now the b7 pawn is guarded and the now
rook to f8 white at least has to try
some something active
and finally c5 Capablanca starts pushing
his passport with b3 and now comes d4
and here King to F do we have King to be
6 by Capablanca and now comes a 3 at
least taking away some of the squares
here so couple on cos King cannot really
enter the Queen side and now comes Luke
to e3 just a powerful move where
Capablanca takes away any any of the
squares for the white king who the
whitening will not be able to increase
his activity and he's waiting for whites
to make a move here we have looked to f7
going after the King side pawns but it
doesn't work capablanca is simply too
fast so once again as it is a really
nice endgame and you will often have an
endgame where you will have a rock
endgame being a pawn up so you want to
make the absolute best move so once
again feel free to pause the video here
and try to find the move capablanca
played in this position once again I'll
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
endgame player and for those you who
just wanna enjoy the show
rook to c3 capo Blancas work is much
faster at gobbling up the pawn
but there is no really no better move
here banks played rook captures on g7
but we have rook captures and c2 with
Czech and now you can either go and try
to protect the h2 pawn but then couple
Blancas passed pawn is just too fast so
here we have King to e1 and now just
king cap rook captures on h2 with the
while defending the h7 pawn so look to
d7 doesn't allow the deep one to be
pushed but now just King to c6 rook to
b8 and not look to be too attacking the
Queen side points we have B for C
capture Sun b48 capture Sun before and
now rook a person before while defending
the d4 pawn we have looked h8 going
after the age 7 point but now just a 5
now kappa blanka has the outside passed
pawn and he will occur of course push it
we have real captures on h7 and now a
for kink the b2 kappa blanka continues
pushing we have a three rook to h1 you
have to be able to block the past bond
we have roof to be to check first King
to d3 and now we have a 2 and here rook
to a 1 here kappa blanka created a very
strong weakness here and the rook will
now have to constantly stay passive here
if you move the rook at any square then
just rook to be one will either force a
rook trade while promoting into a queen
but it's also just a resins material so
we have kinked the d5 with g4 b5 now
cover water starts pushing his utter
passed pawn g5 we've looked the g2
putting the rule behind white passed
pawn but it's really not not a problem
as the black is black is up to pawns so
g6 and now b4 and here white plays g7
so well there are a lot of moves here
you can play you can just put b3 which
is perfectly fine
a couple Blanca goes for for the laziest
option as usual he just captures the
pawn allows the white to capture the 8
to pawn and now goes look the g3 and
here of course these squares are not
available to you so you have to go back
which means couple Blanca will deliver
deliver check and pick up the rock on a2
and the white of course cannot avoid
this we have King to e2 and the now
comes rook to G to check
to D 3 and now capablanca captures the
rook or does he well of course he
doesn't because if he captured the rook
then it's stalemate the King doesn't
allow the White King to go any anywhere
forward the pawn is guarding these two
squares and these three squares are
covered by the rook so this would be a
pretty big big mistake so it's a nice
trap set by mr. Neville Williams banks
capablanca of course doesn't go for the
rookie plays rule g3 with check King e2
and only now b3 the rook has to move we
have worked a 8 and now b2 rook to b8
here we have King to c4 look the CH
check as of course you have to try a few
checks before you resign here capablanca
played King to b3 and it was in this
position animal 54 that Neville Williams
banks the man who mastered both chess
and checkers resigned to the game why
did you resign well there is nothing
more to do here you can deliver one
cheque
but then after king C to end another
cheque black and just cover up with the
rook and now you have really nothing to
do you can go rugby 8 but here wife will
just bring black will just bring a queen
into the game and after captures
captures it's a well the black has a
rock in the pond and the white doesn't
so it's pretty much self-explanatory
but yeah after King to see to mr.
Neville William banks resigned the game
and a wonderful victory in round 2 of
the rice tournament in 1916 for josé
raúl capablanca like I said we will not
be showing the entire tournament but
some of the games that I find really
nice and this game I found really nice
because it's a really nice end game from
the start it's a real Lopez and white
wife plays a a nice game but coupl
Blanca finds that one one inaccuracy
that allows him to grab pawn and then he
just well
plays a better endgame and wins which is
very nice I think it was a very
educational and it's always nice to see
how capablanca just plays normal
principled moves and it seems like the
position wins itself which is what
everyone of course should strive for but
yeah and like I said if you're you know
hungry for more chess I warmly suggest
the immortal game of Isaac Carson that
we already mentioned the the player that
enabled William Banks defeated as he was
a
hmmm how to set a very romantic player
all of his games were really really
aggressive and this one is just a pure
bloodbath so do check it out it will be
the first link you will see in the
description below you know just have an
excellent evening I mean why not yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I mean I certainly have I would like to
thank one Alejandro Armero agüero cisco
bus Adam grip Oh Barry Mack Murdock and
Gregory Gallagher for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous videos your thing called
for watching and I will see you soon are
continuing the capablanca saga checking
up on your suggestions and well seeing
what's what as usual thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day